[Musik]
hey liebe ja was soll ich sagen ich habe
euch verrückt gemacht in den instagram
stories und dafür möchte ich mich jetzt
wo ich entschuldigen
ich habe nämlich letztens kokos würfel
gemacht die mache ich zwischendurch
immer mal gerne einfach weil ich die
richtig lecker finde das sind so ganz
weiche kokos würfel mit schokolade und
schmeckt einfach wie so eine art
baumkuchen findig und das zeige ich euch
jetzt weil mein fehler ich kann es ja
nicht auf instagram zeigen und euch hier
das rezept nicht repräsentieren
daher hätte ja eigentlich hast du ja der
schuldige haben sie erstmal ganz schlimm
wenn ihr uns auf instagram nicht dann
holt das nach aber seid gewarnt haben
sie es ganz schlimm der probiert immer
vor der kamera und kennt viele war er
sagen ich fit haben sich job annehmen
weil da immer ganz viele leckere sachen
probieren darf aber ich werde euch nicht
gemein
ok echt gemein egal ich möchte euch
jetzt nicht weiter auf die folter
spannen ich habe hier meine zutaten
bereit ganz klassische standard zutaten
wir fangen hier an mit zucker dann habe
ich mich und vanille extrakt hier habe
ich sonnenblumenöl könnte auch rapsöl
nehmen backpulver eier und mehl
so und jetzt gebe ich zuallererst die
eier die wenn hier auch nicht getrennt
in die rührschüssel meiner
küchenmaschine wir können natürlich auch
euer handrührgerät verwenden aber es
dauert länger und ich schlage das hier
echt so sieben minuten lang auf höchster
stufe
und da gebe ich auch schon zu kalt
vanille extrakt mit rein weiß dann noch
ein dicker wird
[Musik]
so nach sieben minuten stoppt ich hier
ganz kurz die zeit die eier mast ist
richtig schön dick geworden und hält
cremig und später kriegen wir daraus ein
richtig fluffigen boden und den brauchen
wir auch ich gebe jetzt hier noch die
flüssigen zutaten rein
das heißt einmal das öl und die milch
und butter milch noch ein kleiner tipp
ich gibbs nicht direkt aus dem
kühlschrank reihen die sollte schon
zimmertemperatur haben notfalls einfach
für zehn sekunden in die mikrowelle
geben so und jetzt ganz kurz einrühren
und dann die trockenen zutaten auch ganz
kurz nur noch einräumen und am liebsten
feuer 7 macht das damit ihr auch keine
klümpchen im teig gehabt
[Musik]
so und fertig ist der fluffige boden und
es hat keine acht minuten gedauert
und jetzt gebe ich den auf mein mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
ich mache mir hier ein bisschen platz
und wollte euch noch den tipp geben
verwendet gerne einen bug ram damit ihr
nicht so viel verschwendung habe damit
der teig auch nicht ungleichmäßig back
und an allen seiten schön gerade ist
[Musik]
sind teilt habe ich jetzt noch glatt
verstrichen mit der teil karte und jetzt
ganz ganz wichtig die maße beachtet 26 x
36 cm habe ich jetzt meinen ba kram
eingestellt bei mir braucht er jetzt im
backofen bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze 20 minuten maximal 21 aber
nicht länger auf die maße eben
abgestimmt also beachtet die maßen dann
dauert es bei euch auch mit 20 minuten
in den kleineren back rahmen habt dann
braucht er länger weil der teig höher
ist anders rum wenn ihr ein größeres
back ich hab dann braucht ihr nicht so
lang so und jetzt gebe ich das wie
gesagt in ofen und wir sehen uns gleich
wieder so der boden besitzt durch
gebacken ich mache immer ganz gerne die
stäbchen probe ich mir einfach so einen
schaschlikspieß oder ein zahnstocher
steht hier das in den teig und wenn
nichts mehr hängen bleibt dann ist der
boden durch gebacken und jetzt denke ich
dass noch so ungefähr fünf bis acht
minuten mit einem sauberen tuch und las
dass ein bisschen ausdampfen aber wir
schneiden das gleich noch durch während
es noch warm ist jetzt zeige ich euch
aber die schokoladen tränke quasi und
dafür benötigt ihr ganz einfach viel zu
taten
ich habe hier milch dann habe ich zb tag
overture könnte auch gerne voll mich
nehmen zucker und etwas butter das gehen
wird alles in den topf lasst uns
miteinander schmelzen und so dass es
sich eben verbindet und wir gleich damit
weitermachen können
[Musik]
so die schokosoße ist fertig einfach nur
kurz an die seite stellen außerdem
brauchen wir natürlich auch noch ganz
viel kokos und der boden ist jetzt auch
noch lauwarm einmal das geschirrtuch weg
hauptsache ich sagt geschirrtuch nur
durch ein sauberes geschirr und weil ich
selber keine sauberen geschirrtücher
mehr ab alle in der wäsche nämlich hier
eine tischdecke
so jetzt schlafe ich mir mein tortenring
müssen jetzt erstmal den bug rahmen ab
dem das ganze vom backblech runter wobei
ihr könnt auch auf dem backblech
schneiden das wäre ja auch kein problem
aber ich habe gleich auch noch meint
orten einteiler und dann teile ich mir
alles perfekt ein bis alles gleich groß
ist
[Musik]
sonst jetzt nehme ich mir mein messer am
besten mit wellenschliff und schneide
das einmal den quadraten entlang und die
ränder die können wir uns gleich schon
haben sagt klar und zu weich ist der
boden wie wollten einfach wirkliche
kannst du nicht einfach mal einen kuchen
backen griechen kuchen ja und ich will
mich aber drauf schlagen
okay man trotzdem richtig super softe
matratze richtig gut ist meint auch
direkt weiter
der boden ist jetzt auch noch lauwarm
das heißt wird gehen jetzt in lauwarmen
boden in die schokolade
wichtig ist die schokolade darf jetzt
nicht heiß sein die kann auch schon
abgekühlt sein
da müsste ich vorstellen wenn der warme
wohnen jetzt in die auch sehr sehr warme
schokolade getunkt wird dann könnte es
sein dass es kaputt geht und das wollen
wir nicht ich zeige euch das jetzt und
dann sind die eigentlich auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
und fertig sind die kokons würfel die
sich eigentlich too much i nennen das
ich hoffe ich es richtig aus ist ein
bosnisches rezept um bevor er jetzt in
die video beschreibung guckt um euch die
zutaten zu screenshot abonniert auf
jeden fall meinen kanal
das ist ein bisschen was was sie uns
zurückgegeben euch ja die rezepte mit
cli garantie und daher gerne abonnieren
falls ihr noch kein abonnent sind dann
macht sie unbedingt nach sie halten drei
tage lang sind mega mega soft und ich
bezweifle dass er sie drei tage lang
irgendwie eine küche stehen ab ohne dass
sie jeder auffordern wird unbedingt
nachmachen den kanal natürlich
abonnieren wie gesagt ein bäumchen nach
oben geben und dann lesen wir und
schreiben in den kommentaren miteinander
schreibt mir doch gerne ob es das
irgendwie in eurer kultur ausgibt ich
glaube in england heißen so lenken
es gibt ganz viele wörter dafür aber
wichtig ist dass sie extrem lecker
schmecken haben so und ich können uns
jetzt mit einem café und euch noch einen
wunderschönen tag und bis zum nächsten
mal auf die couch im kies
[Musik]